new year new me it's a phrase pretty
much
everyone says as they approach the end
of one year and the beginning of another
turns out this a phrase of folks on
netflix must have been nuttering as they
put together their lineup for january
2020.
beginning january 2020 netflix
subscribers can sing their teeth into
four stellar action flicks
and let it suffice to say it's all
killer no filler
thrill ride anyone based on the marvel
comics character ghost rider styles
nicolas cage
as a titular superhero and rest assured
he's not your average motorcycle
stuntman turned fiery avenger on wheels
that's coming your way on january 1st
you can check out the 2017 action
thriller american assassin starring
dylan o'brien as a man hell-bent on
avenging the death of his fiancee
after she's murdered by terrorists are
you a big fan of fantasy films you're
officially in luck
netflix will be bringing plenty of magic
into our lives and soon
on january 1st guillermo del toro's
sprawling oscar-winning dark fantasy
pan's labyrinth hits the streaming
service
the story involves a young girl who
discovers a mythical world of which he
is the ruler
oh and you'll definitely want to check
out the second and third movies in peter
jackson's lord of the rings trilogy
the two towers and the return of the
king will both be available for
streaming beginning on january 1st
here's a happy new year's resolution for
you don't let a drama free day go by in
january 2020.
there are loads of acclaimed dramas
coming to netflix including catch me if
you can starring leonardo dicaprio he
plays a brilliant con artist and bank
robber
on the run from an fbi agent played by
tom hanks the film is a total delight
particularly if you're into all sorts of
wily cat and mouse shenanigans
my name is frank taylo i'm a co-pilot
for pan am i'd like to
cash this check here and then i'd like
to take you out for a steak dinner
let the games begin on january 1st
another leonardo dicaprio film is coming
to netflix that same day
and it's quite the mind melter inception
involves a burglar who can creep into
people's dreams
and pluck out all their secrets prepare
to have your brain scrambled by this
beguiling endlessly entertaining film
there's even more gripping goodness
coming your way on january 1st
including the whipsmart comedy drama up
in the air starring george clooney and
anna kendrick on january 18th
the bling ring starts streaming based on
a true story this stylist drama involves
a group of crafty teenagers who figure
out how to rob the luxurious homes of
celebrities
in the mood for something completely
different we are your friends start
streaming on january 27th and it's a
music drama that just so happens to be
directed by max joseph of catfishfame
get ready to laugh because netflix is
bringing plenty of classic comedies to
the streamer
in january 2020. first up is ferris
bueller's day off an iconic comedy about
cutting school
in favor of all sorts of mischievous
hijinks that will be available to stream
on january 1st that's also the day you
can check out the classic
1971 musical comedy willy wonka and the
chocolate factory
boy what a great series this one made
wonka
this is kind of strange yeah strange
charlie but it's fun
and if that's not quite enough whimsy
for you tim burton's 2005 update
charlie and the chocolate factory also
begins streaming on january 1st
that's not all hitch starring will smith
is coming to netflix on january 1st
along with the zany romp yes man
starring jim carrey
then on january 15th netflix starts
streaming the qtc 2002 teen comedy big
fat liar
sure why not there's only one stand-up
comedy special coming to netflix in
january 2020
but it's one that you absolutely should
not miss comedian fortune thiemster
brings her first ever netflix comedy
special to the streamer
on january 21st in fortune feemster
sweet and salty
the office christmas party star
reminisces about her childhood
including her experiences as a girl
scout she also opens up about her
family's absurd relationship with a
certain chicken wing restaurant chain
and reveals how one film helped her come
to terms with her sexuality
scared perhaps you should be netflix is
adding tons of amazing horror films and
thrillers to the streaming service in
january 2020.
on january 1st you can watch the ring a
supernatural thriller about a cursed
videotape that kills anyone who watches
it within seven days
that same day you can check out the
talented mr ripley a twisted thriller
starring matt damon
as a charming con artist and serial
killer finally
what lies beneath is a supernatural tale
starring harrison ford and michelle
pfeiffer
as a well-to-do couple living in a
haunted house expect
plenty of twists and turns in that one
then on january 30th brian de palma's
raising kane
hits netflix this underrated gem stars
john lithgow
as dr carter nix a brilliant child
psychologist suffering from multiple
personality disorder
following a shocking discovery one of
those personalities a titular kane
comes to the fore and carter's actions
grow increasingly violent
this is some trashy twisted fun that's
chock-a-block with unforgettable
performances
all of which come from lithgow a handful
of netflix originals are presenting
their final seasons
including and with an e on january 3rd
and the ranch on january 24th
other shows will be continuing their
highly successful runs keep an eye out
for the sixth season of the comedy
series grayson frankie on january 15th
then there's the second season of the
runaway head sex education on january
17th
meanwhile the spellbinding third season
of chilling adventures of sabrina
is coming for you on january 24th and
the second season of the documentary
series i am a killer
starts streaming on january 31st of
course we'll be remiss not to mention
what's arguably the best tv offering on
netflix
the sixth and final season of bojack
horseman arrives on the last day of
january
and you definitely won't want to miss
that today sucks
the story of my life is that i never get
anything nice
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you